hey what's good everybody my name is
Javon Walton and these are my favorite
snacks
now these right here
all time favorite okay I can eat a whole
bag of these no problem these right here
dude God I love the green ones
they're all just so good and I eat them
all the time
[Applause]
I'm 100 a sour person I absolutely love
sour I can eat sour all day long my
favorite is warheads and sour skittles I
don't know sometimes I'm just like I
need to take a break from this it's
feeling like an addiction all right
that's too much sour skittles
we got Takis absolutely love these but
the only bad thing about Takis is that
they're dirty they get your hands filthy
and it is so hard to wash that stuff out
of your hands
sweet
make sure you look I already go
all over my hands
but they're great love these so so much
with certain things I am a spicy food
person but with other things no hot
wings I can't handle talkies and stuff
like that I can handle but I don't know
there's my limits for sure next up we
got a smoothie and honestly I don't
think there's anything that beats
smoothies like it's just the best thing
me and my sister we go to Smoothie King
all the time and I don't know it's just
unbeatable it'll fill you up and it
tastes amazing
so as a boxer you know when I'm getting
into fight mode and all that my diet is
definitely a little more restricted you
know so smoothies are a great go-to for
that I got a film coming out called
Samaritan uh me and Mr Sly are starring
in it I don't really get to talk boxing
on set too much so it was nice to be
able to have that you know and we would
argue about boxing all the time and he's
a boxing historian so he knows his stuff
foreign
people that don't know there's a fly
that's been flying around for God knows
how long and he won't leave
no I can't get him I'm sorry he's just
like the that has to be the fastest fly
I've ever seen I'm gonna punching him
out of the air
goldfish
now these little guys aren't good for
you I'll say that right now but they
sure are amazing I've just remembered
eating them at a very young age
and absolutely loving them so it's not
something I've gotten over I love the
colorful ones too but I like these like
you know like when you're in like
kindergarten and you got the little
paper towel and then the goldfish on it
that your teacher puts down and that's
just unbeatable man and I just love
goldfish ever since
Rice Krispies
[Music]
thing is food like this they don't fill
you up at all but they taste absolutely
amazing I love these and kind of going
back to like the Goldfish thing like I
remember just like a young age like and
um a place called Zaxby's near us like
they would always have and the kids meal
Rice Krispie treats and they were always
amazing so I don't not love these ever
since
um I use it as a little mini pre-workout
so
it's it's good I like them a lot Zaxby's
to people who've never been to Zaxby's
it's a lot like a Cane's just chicken
like chicken sandwiches they have these
things called Nibbler meals they're like
long sliders almost but with chicken so
it's it's interesting they're really
really good though I love Zaxby's I
don't know I like it more than games not
trying to start a debate
peanuts
and I don't know I just love snacking on
these little guys
wrong way to
there you go all right I don't know I
love snacking on these they're just such
a great little snack and these will
actually kind of fill you up after a
while
I don't know I think they're really good
and you can't go wrong with them
boom yogurt I think you can eat yogurt
as a snack and as a meal and that's what
I love so much about it and you can put
so many things inside of it you know you
can put granola
oh there's not so many things you can
put but you can you can put fruits you
can put granola and there's just like
there's a few things you can put inside
inside of yogurt and that's what I love
about it so loved yogurt always loved
yogurt
and I will continue to love yogurt
[Music]
are y'all these were my favorite snacks
let me know y'all's favorite snacks but
make sure to go check out Samaritan on
Amazon Prime do you guys get any more of
the Skittles I can take
story thanks
[Music]